hi everyone
i am arno and i work as a data scientist
at selden which is a company specialized
in machine learning
deployments with my colleagues i also
maintain the open source small
explainability python library alibi
as well as alibi detects which is a
package that focuses on outlier drift
and adversarial detection
and during the next 30 minutes i will
talk a little bit more about how you can
use
open source tools like this and to
monitor your ml models in production
the talk is structured as follows i will
first provide a brief overview of why
you should care about monitoring the
first place
and then i will walk you through an
excruciatingly long notebook
to illustrate how we can do this in
practice
so as you probably know the machine
learning life cycle extends well beyond
the deployment stage and a big challenge
in envelopes is post deployment
monitoring to ensure
you have a continued high quality
service provided by the ml model
but unlike traditional software
monitoring which involves logging
metrics like request
latency frequency or server loads
ml applications are actually more
demanding and we identify
four main areas for additional areas
following model deployment which are key
for the success of
any ml application so first you would
need to monitor your model performance
as well as metrics related to the
incoming data
then we can go on to do detect drift
outliers and adversarial instances and
finally we want to be able to explain
our model predictions as well
so for all of these areas there are both
algorithmic and infrastructure
challenges and in this talk i will
address both so the algorithmic and
infrastructure sites
in the context of outlier adversarial
and drift detection components
but before we dive into the different
detection components
let's take a brief look at monitoring
model performance and metrics related to
the incoming data
so we differentiate between the two
because the first requires obviously a
ground truth
and which comes with its own challenges
for performance metrics the labels need
to be fed into some system
that calculates the metrics on the fly
and this can be done by an endpoint so
for instance
and the open source ml deployment
platform southern core
will expose a dedicated send feedback
endpoint which accepts labels and
performs some
user-defined metric calculations which
are often related to some business kpis
we also need to decide on thresholds to
take action as well as which action
needs to be taken it is actually harder
than it sounds because
the thresholds will depend on the use
case and in some cases we actually
benefit from more sophisticated
algorithms like
change point detection so the action
they've been taking then
is also not obvious because it might
range from doing nothing at all
if the service is fine to taking the
model offline
or trigger the model for retraining but
then
another question arises like which data
would be using for the retraining
[Music]
and both types of metrics the
performance and the incoming data
metrics
are stateful and typically require
selection of appropriate time periods as
well
finally incoming data metrics range in
sophistication from
simple pointwise univariate estimates
like mean and quantiles etc
to multivariate or more sophisticated
density estimates
and this brings us to outlier detection
because at the core
it's basically a bit of a density
estimation problem
so why bother doing authority outlier
detection in the first place
um mainly because it's key for ml models
because they often don't generalize with
a lot of distribution
and on top of that they can be overly
confident on anomalous instances so
that can be because of a lack of
calibration or for instance unreliable
likelihood estimates
so as a result we can't really trust
model predictions and outliers and we
should be very careful in a production
setting
but this is a very hard unsolved problem
on real data
because there's no real silver bullet
and a suitable detector really depends
on
for instance the modality of the data
the dimensionality etc
and we also often don't really have
access to
a significant amount of labeled outliers
that are often scarce
and that makes the problem
semi-supervised the best
so while outlier detection is mainly
about spotting changes in the input data
and it's called p of x
adversarial instances actually aren't
that different in the input so they're
only marginally changed in the input
space
but with a maximum effect the maximum
impact on the output of the model b y
given x
because at the core adversarial
instances are often instances
which are very carefully crafted by
applying some small perturbations to the
original data
with the goal to trick the machine
learning model and change for instance
the
predicted class for a classifier and
this is
illustrated by the simple image here
where the almost invisible perturbations
flip the stop sign
into a yield sign and it's obviously
crucial for safety critical ml systems
like autonomous driving or healthcare
applications
to detect these kinds of adversarial
instances and ideally correct them as
well
and so far we've looked at outliers and
other cell examples but
both are actually referring to
individual instances when we
look at talk about data drift or shift
detection
um we actually look at whether two
samples are drawn from the same
underlying distribution or not
via statistical hypothesis tests so now
we're not looking at individual
instances but
we're looking at distributions and the
goal of the the drift detector is
therefore to identify
when the distribution of the requests
for the deployed model so the live
requests
starts to diverge from the training data
and as a result the model predictions
might become unreliable
we will investigate um two main types of
drift so we'll investigate covariate
shift
which is drifting the input distribution
and shift of the predict the predicted
label or the prediction distribution
so both are types of unsupervised drift
since we assume we're in a setting where
we don't have access to
labels of the the live data of the
deployed
model and in practice and especially on
high dimensional data like images
we will follow a two-step approach so
first
we apply a dimensionality reduction step
and then you can conduct your favorite
two sample tests of choice
uh like the commodore smearing off with
optional multivariate correction
or maximum discrepancy with a
permutation test
and the the example notebook will shed
more light on the
on the two-step approach so that says
let's just move to the notebook
so i must admit i actually
cheated a little bit and already ran the
notebook due to time constraints and
also maybe
a little bit because i didn't want to
break the notebook
and start recording all over again
so for the data set we're looking at a
very simple data sets
which many of you will probably already
be very familiar
um and it's the c5 data set so it
consists of 60 000 images
32 by 32 rgb which are
equally distributed over 10 classes like
airplanes automobiles birds cuts etc
so here you can see a couple of the
images
so let's go straight into our first kind
of
functionality the first thing we want to
test outlier detection
in this case we'll start off with a
simple
variation auto encoder which is a fairly
common
type of outlier detector
and in a nutshell when we look at
vanilla auto encoders
they consist of an encoder and a decoder
and the encoder protects the projects
the
input onto a latent space which is
typically of lower dimension and the
input
while the decoder actually tries to
reconstruct the
input from the latent vector and for a
variational to encoder or
va this latent vector is not
deterministic but sampled from some
learned posterior distribution with a
mean mu and a standard deviation sigma
as
shown in the image so we sample from
that
and then we try to reconstruct the
original image
so for more information on vies
definitely check the
fantastic blog post which is linked in
the notebook
and for outlier detection what we will
do is we'll train the detector on normal
data so it can reconstruct the in-layers
very well
and then when the deployed model the
deployed detector
sees outliers it will not be able to
reconstruct it very well
so this leads to a higher reconstruction
error and if this error is above a
certain defined thresholds the instance
can be flagged as
an anomaly
so first of all we actually already
pre-trained the detector on
c510 which is stored in a public google
cloud
bucket so we'll just fetch it from there
but alternatively here's the code to uh
to trade from scratch so it's pretty
simple what you just need to do
is uh define an encoder
a decoder and a latent dimension uh
posits to the outlier detection object
and then apply a very simple
fit step you can then save the detector
like any detector in
alibi detect with the simple save the
texture
detector function
so let's see what actually comes out of
the vie how it reconstructs a normal
instance
uh in this case the original instances
are both uh we reconstructed them both
it's not the prettiest boat in the world
but
uh it will do for our purpose
we also need to find a certain threshold
to detect the outlier
outliers and finding a good threshold is
tricky and definitely not intuitive at
all
and that's why there is a simple
infrared threshold
functionality um to find
hopefully a sensible sensible value so
what you need to do is just specify
roughly what fraction of the data set
should be considered as normal or in
liars
via the threshold percentage so in this
case like 99 of the data
is considered to be in distribution and
and then it will infer a threshold from
there
to test the outliers what we're actually
going to do is we're going to
create some artificial outliers by
applying a random noise mask to the
original instances
and in this case you can see we just uh
we're adding some noise
to the uh to the bolt here um
and we'll uh we'll we'll run the uh the
out fire detector on that so
we'll uh we'll just uh call a simple
predict step
on the sample which is both the
noise the perturbed instance and the
original one
and you can see on the original one it
did not detect
it was the reconstruction it was below
the threshold so it did not detect an
outlier
and for the uh for the third one it did
show
uh it did figure out this is clearly an
outlier
and we can see as well that's a nice
thing about vae
we can see per channel what basically
the higher
outlier scores the higher reconstruction
errors were and it's pretty clear that
some patches of the of the noise mask
are flagged um as outlier areas
so now it's clear how the outlier
detector works we can actually
deploy it and for deployment here we'll
use salon core which is as mentioned
earlier an open source deployment
platform on kubernetes
and we also use the eventing based
project k native which connects
serverless components with event streams
and this will be clear from the diagram
so as you can see the diagram
on the left we have the selden core
deployment
with a payload logger which sends events
containing model requests and response
payloads to the
native broker and the broker can then
farm these out via programmable triggers
and
and this can be farmed out to different
serverless components like the
outlier adversarial or drift detection
modules
and it also asynchronously then the
events
produced by these components can be sent
further for instance to alerting
our storage modules so this clean
separation of concerns
between the model and the monitoring
components actually allows them to be
scaled separately as needed
and kinetic makes it then possible to
scale
the services down to zero if no requests
come in and scale up as the demand
increases
my colleague was already kind enough to
configure a cluster on digitalocean with
southern core installed
but the necessary configuration steps to
set everything up from scratch
can be found in the in the linked
notebook
okay let's walk through it so first we
need to get the ip address of the
ingress gateway for our cluster
to direct requests to and we also get
the
host name of the outlier service as well
then we define some simple utility
functions um
for the prediction of the deployed model
and the uh and the outlier detector
so let's just run those
on an actual instance so you can see
we'll make a prediction on the original
instance
the classifier and the resonant
classifier
correctly says okay it's a ship and
and then what we can see is we will
check the
the message to the dumper for the
deployments
for the output of the outlier detector
and the message dumper will contain the
information of the outlier detector such
as like the feature-wise scores and
whether it's an outlier or not
and it again says okay it's not an
outlier we then
do uh the same on the per third instance
uh
we show it here quickly um make a
prediction uh although it's still a ship
the outlier detector as we can see from
the message damper
correctly figures out it's an outlier
and again highlights the same
uh feature kind of uh the pixels where
it
why it thinks it's an outlier so it
highlights the mask
the noise mask so okay more or less
mission accomplished
and we can uh we can move on from
outlier detection to adversarial
detection
for adversarial detection um we'll
follow
the methodology in a paper uh called
adversarial detection and correction by
matching prediction distributions
and the method is pretty simple pretty
straightforward um
i'll try to give a clear overview
very briefly so as mentioned earlier
adversarial examples are almost
indistinguishable from the original
instance
but they fool the classifier and change
the model prediction
and since the impact is mainly felt in
the model output space
this is where the detector will focus on
because there's almost no change in the
input of the adversary instance compared
to the original one
but there's a big change in the output
so in the prediction
so the idea for the adversarial detector
is as follows
first we train an auto encoder but not
with us goal
to reconstruct the original input x but
instead we want to make sure that the
classification model predictions on the
output of the auto encoder
x prime are the same as on the original
instance x
so we don't incentivize x prime to look
like x at all
and as a result in the carefully crafted
perturbations around x which fool the
classifier
they actually do not transfer to x prime
we can then simply compute an
adversarial score which we measure as
the kl divergence between the classifier
prediction on the original instance x
and x prime
and if the score is above a threshold
again the instance will be labeled as an
adversarial instance
and if the instance is adversarial we
can actually use the prediction
of the classifier on x prime instead of
x for
x for kind of downstream purposes
and this procedure is shown in the in
the diagram
more detail can be found in the in the
text blob here in the notebook
and a in the paper which is linked
okay so then um because we're
using a slightly different model we're
gonna add some utility functions to
simply rescale the data below the
pre-trained classifier as well
um and just make sure that uh that our
resnet classifier
is uh is correct and then and we just
check the uh double check the accuracy
so it's
about 93 percent on the test sets of
c410
which is uh which is decent enough
and we'll apply two types of adversarial
attacks
on the data sets the first one is a
carolinian wagner and the other one is
the slide attack and they're
they're pretty powerful as you can see
because the accuracy of the
machine learning model of the of the
resnet classifier basically goes from 93
to
zero percent and we can also see some of
the images
of the original compared to the
adversarial images
so the original here is a is a plane
the the model the resonant classifier
correctly identified it as a plane
and the adversarial image is basically
looks the same but it's classified as a
ship
same for the frog which is turned into a
bird
so um this is clearly clearly an issue
that we want to rectify
same as for the outlier detector we can
we can fetch
a detector from the google cloud buckets
but again you can just train one from
scratch yourself
it's pretty straightforward same thing
as for the outlier detector we just
define an encoder and decoder and pass
that
with the uh the classification model and
to the
adversarial detection objects then we
call the fit
method on on the adversarial detector
and can save it in exactly the same way
as the outlier detector
okay so let's see what uh what actually
actually the impact is
so as you saw before the accuracy after
the attack was reduced almost zero
but then when we look at the accuracy on
the reconstructed instances
by the adversarial auto encoder the
accuracy is brought back up to well over
80 percent
so that that's pretty good that's not
bad at all
and let's investigate like what is what
it looks like and
and why um why this what is going on
really
so we see again the original c410 image
which is correctly classified as an
airplane
with an adversarial score here uh of
almost zero
but then when we look at the other cell
image which looks almost identical to
the original
but classifies the image as a dock the
adversarial score has
spiked up to over five and interestingly
enough
in the last column here you can see the
reconstruction of the instance
by the adversarial to encoder so as you
can as you can see it's clearly not
incentivized to reconstruct
the the inputs but it just cares about
the decision boundaries it just
cares about making the same
correct model prediction as the original
instance and the
the small perturbation which is applied
in the adversarial instance
does not transfer to this kind of noisy
looking image
and the noisy looking image actually
produces the right uh the right class
you can see the same thing for um for
other
uh instances like the horse which is
pulled into
a truck but actually the uh the
reconstruction by the adversarial auto
encoder
corrects it back to a horse and this is
the same
for the slide attacks
we can we can plot this for all the
instances and see that
the uh then constructor receiver
operator curve
and we can actually see that for both
the uh the attack methods the kalini
wagner and the slide attack methods
and it's the detection is doing a very
good job
um so the auc is
close to or above uh 0.9 um which is not
bad at all given that their accuracy
went all the way back down to zero
and same for the other plus for the
outlier detector we can just
infer thresholds
that we will use further down the line
so what i want to show now
is how the diagram is really executed in
a very simple way
by the um by the adversarial detector
and so what i'll do here is just sample
um some new uh data sets where 25
percent of the instances
come from the carlini wagner attack and
the rest from the original c410 test set
so if you look at the accuracy on this
new um new data sets
it's it's not great it's so it's because
of the uh the attacks that i the
the adversary instance that i introduced
it's all the way
down to less than 74 percent
what i will do now is basically run the
the correction
functionality from the other cell
detector on the same data set
so what this basically does is just
execute
the diagram that we saw here so it will
reconstruct the original input it will
calculate the adversarial score then we
will check
is the adversarial score above a
threshold so
is it an adversary instance or not um
if it's below the threshold we just use
the um the model prediction
on the original instance if it's above
the threshold we'll use the prediction
on the uh on the reconstructed instance
by the
adversarial auto encoder and by doing so
um so which is called the simple the
correct methods
we actually bring the accuracy not not
all the way back up but we bring it back
up to
82 so that's uh that's all like like a
good eight percent
improvement um over the over the
uncorrected
um method so that's pretty good and we
can actually further boost the
performance quite a bit
um by adding some other tricks which are
highlighted in the paper like
temperature scaling on the outputs
and and including the scale divergence
and
of not just the output but also of the
hidden layers of the model
so all these functionalities are
implemented in alibi detects
so you can just play around with it
with it there so for the final part of
the talk
we actually moved to drift detection and
as mentioned before the drift detector
applies uh feature wise to sample com
kolmogorov smirnoff tests followed by a
multivariate correction
of the obtained p values for each
feature because
for high dimensional data like images we
first want to reduce the dimensionality
before computing the ks
statistics imagine for high dimensional
image you need to
for each pixel basically start doing a
ks test and then aggregate those
that's that's not really very very very
useful so
we need to do other preprocessing step
to reduce the dimensionality
and then we can detect rift on the
pre-processed data
and there's two methods we will follow
we will basically follow suggestions
made in the paper
called the following loudly and
empirical study of methods for detecting
dataset shift and the first one is
basically to use
an untrained auto encoder so just a
randomly initialized auto encoder
which projects the inputs on the lower
latent dimension
and this allows to measure covariate
shift
the second method actually uses the
softmax output of the classifier
and allows us to enables us to detect
drift
in the distribution of the model
predictions
we use the same data set c for them but
to test the drift detector on
we'll also use c510cc so c510c
um is actually contains the same image
as a c410
but corrupted by different types of
noise blur brightness etc at different
severity levels
so the more severe the corruption the
bigger the impact on your classifier
performance
we then randomly sample a reference data
set from cpr10 against which we will
test our drift as well as the data sets
coming from the same
c410 test sets and we should not reject
the null hypothesis
since it comes from the same data and
then we'll also
sample some some data from four
different types of
perturbations you can see them here we
use gaussian noise
motion blur brightness and pixelation so
as an instance here
you can see the original image gaussian
noise applied to it
motion blur etc etc and you can see that
they really impact the the accuracy of
the original classifier a lot so the
original classifier
is around 93 percent accurate but this
is brought
all the way down to 22 for gaussian
noise
so given a drop in performance we really
really want to detect
this harmful drift okay
let's do it then so first we'll use the
first pre-processing method the
uae the uh untrained the randomly
initialized auto encoder
uh it's pretty simple so kind of getting
used to
defining an encoder now and a decoder
the encoder we just
passed to the ks drift detector
as pre-process quarks together
with the reference data sets and a
desired level of p-value for the test
because we don't need to fit
any data we can just predict straight
away
let's first check whether detector flags
drift on the data sets which comes from
the same desktop
distribution as a on c4 10 as the
reference set
and it doesn't so that that's good and
we can also
see for the the p-values of the
individual features
and that they're well above um well
above 0.05 so they're
they're kind of they're kind of on the
same distribution
when we do the same thing on the
different corrupted data sets
for each single one of them it's a clear
yes it's clearly drifting so that's good
we do the same thing for the other um
pre-processing method so
which we call bbs yes which comes from
another paper
called detecting correcting for label
shift with black box predictors
so here we use the softmax layer from
the glassfire to detect the drift
but we can actually use other hidden
layers as well
just by specif specifying the the layer
index
which we want to extract and again we
just pass it as
pre-processing quarks to the drift
detector
and run the exact same um the exact same
prediction methods uh same as for the
other preprocessing methods it doesn't
drift
on the data coming from the same
distribution but it does on the
perturbed instances
so it's all very very fun and exciting
to uh to detect
drifts on um uh monitoring
uh via covert and label shift but at the
end of the day what we really want to
get i want to
measure and care about is whether the
model performance has been impacted
like is there model deterioration going
on and can we flag that
and the great thing is we can actually
leverage the adversarial detector for
this
so instead of um using a pre-processing
step like the the encoder
we can just pause the adversarial
scoring function
so the exact same under cell detector we
just bought the scoring function which
spits out one number so it's a
univariate ks test
and we measure drift uh on that
and interestingly enough um that works
very well
so uh again on the uh original kind of
tested distribution it doesn't flag
drift on the others it does
and what is actually more interesting is
we when we look at this plot here
what this plot shows on the left y axis
it shows the adversarial score and
the right access the classifier accuracy
then the x-axis
displays basically increasing corruption
severity levels
applied to the c510 data sets and the
orange bars at each level showed a
scores for the instances
where the model predicted the correct
clause for both the original and the
preferred instance
and the green class shows on the other
hand this course where the model was
initially correct
but because of the corruption the model
flipped to an incorrect or wrong
prediction
so this is what we call harmful drift
and it's clear that at all severity
levels
the drift score for the non-harmful
instances
are actually very similar to that of the
original c410 test set
but for the harmful instances it's way
higher so it will
be flagged up and picked up as drift so
that's that's really really good
and in the same way as the outlier
detector with using the same cluster
we can also just um inspect the drift
components
so um in this case we'll just accumulate
batches of
5000 instances in the drift detector
before we actually make the drift
prediction so this can be specified in
the deployment yaml
and it is very flexible so you can see
here we basically accumulate in batches
of hundreds
and the drift detector will only make a
prediction once it's
the batch is full so once we read five
five thousand instances
and then uh drift will be flagged or not
so we do this on the original data set
and again there's no drift
and when we do this on the corrupted
data set with with gaussian noise
and we do we do pick up drift so the uh
the deployed model does its job
so great thanks a lot and this brings us
to the end of the talk
and in a nutshell um to conclude i can't
stress enough how important it is to
monitor your machine learning models and
incoming data distributions if you want
to stay on top of how your model is
doing in the world
and while there is no real silver bullet
for any of the
outlier adversarial or drift detection
tasks there are tools available like
aloe vera detect salon core and k native
which are flexible enough to tailor the
detectors to your needs and also deploy
them in production
so for those who made it all the way to
the end thanks a lot for listening and
i'm looking forward to answering all of
your questions during the q a
and the notebook with all the examples
will also be made available on the alibi
detect github repo